(mouse clicks)
(soft electronic music)
- When we think of the distinct claims,
dependence, developmental modulation,
promise, and innocence,
those are the main components
that drive a public understanding
of our current conception of childhood.
The reality, of course, is this.
Many of you have met Omran Daqneesh
through this photograph.
Omran was a child pulled out of the rubble
in Aleppo, Syria after bombardment
by Russian and Syrian jets.
This photograph went viral
because of its compelling imagery
and how it challenges
the four distinct claims
that I just went through
before, particularly innocence.
Now, the thing to remember
about Omran Daqneesh,
this is a tragic occurrence,
tragic photograph,
but it's not unique.
On the same day that this
photograph was taken,
there were 12 other children his age
pulled out of the same rubble,
taken to the same emergency room,
that this photograph captures
not something unusual
or unique, but something
that had become routine.
What I'm going to discuss is the reality
that this photograph represents,
and this is what kids like
Omran were confronting
on a daily basis for
more than seven years.
The implications of, how do we protect,
and how do we respond
to this kind of assault
will be my conversation for
the next half hour or so.
We also have a special focus
on the particular
vulnerabilities and strengths
of children with disabilities
caught up in violent conflict.
To begin, let's recognize that children
caught up in armed
conflict is not unusual.
These are countries, different levels
of armed violence as of a few weeks ago.
It's not unusual that about a quarter
of the world's children are living
in places in armed conflict.
This is common, and our work at Stanford,
here at UCSF, with
colleagues around the world
is trying to address the implications,
both protective implications
as well as response
implications, of this fact.
The other thing to remember is that most
of our protections for civilians,
particularly for children, were built
after World War II.
The Geneva Conventions particularly,
most international
humanitarian law came about
after World War II.
Interstate wars, France fighting Germany,
US fighting Japan, but if you look
at where violent conflict
is taking place now
in the world, it's totally dominated
by intrastate, what many
would call civil wars,
and most of these wars are protracted.
They're not two, three, four-year wars,
which is long enough, of course,
but some can go on for decades,
like in the Eastern Congo
and the North and South Kivu,
and even in Syria and Iraq now,
the wars decade long,
Afghanistan approaching several decades.
These are protracted civil wars
that we are talking about.
One, particularly, that I will use
as a case is the battle that took place
in northern Iraq in the city of Mosul.
It's Iraq's second largest city.
It was taken over by ISIS 2014,
and the battle for Mosul was
the Iraqi security forces
with US coalition
backing taking Mosul back
in the fall of 2016, 2017.
This is Mosul before the battle.
This is Mosul after the battle.
There's virtually complete destruction,
and it took not several
months, which was expected.
It took nine months, and we were part
of a small team that were tasked
with evaluating the international response
to this, civilian casualties,
which had become extremely controversial
for several different reasons,
but our job was basically to see
how, in fact, civilians were cared for,
protected during this battle
that lasted more than nine months,
and basically destroyed the whole city.
We were looking at how groups
not only in Mosul, but are in the theater,
including Syria, like
here, the White Helmets,
responded to civilian casualties,
and particularly for
me, as a pediatrician,
responded to the needs of children.
Now, when we think about the impact of war
on human beings, but
particularly on children,
the first thing to recognize
is that there's a category
of effects that we would
call direct effects.
They are exposure to bullets and bombs.
It's primarily trauma, and
mortality is the crucial impact,
but there's also morbidity.
The human toll in terms of morbidity
from direct exposure to bombs and bullets,
to combat operations,
is usually between five
and 10 times greater than the mortality.
If we know that 100 people died,
we can expect that the disabilities
and the ongoing morbidity
associated with being exposed
to those battles is between
five and 10 times greater.
I'm going to show you this little guy
who I met in Mosul about a month
after the fighting had died down.
He's a little guy who
had his foot amputated
because he was exposed
to an explosive device
that was triggered by ISIS.
The thing that is particularly compelling
about this child was not only
that he was badly injured,
but it also reflected something
about the changing nature of warfare,
and the changing nature of combatants
that is important to address, to confront,
as we think about children in war now.
That is that this little guy's mother
and father were both ISIS suicide bombers.
He was orphaned because
both parents had triggered
suicide vests as they
approached Iraqi security forces
on the front line.
This is dynamic, and the challenges
to children are dynamic as well.
The also important mental
health implications
of this exposure to such violence,
we did a study in Bosnia
during the Bosnian fighting.
This was in a camp.
Most of the children that we
interviewed were in the camp
for less than six months,
but the experience that they had,
which is mimicked in Iraq and Syria,
many of the other places that
I'll discuss, is profound,
that separation, death in the family,
witnessing violence to a family member
was pretty close to universal.
We had a bunch of different outcomes
that we looked at, but
virtually all the kids had had
deep emotional trauma, and we don't know
what happened to them
subsequent to our study
because the camp members were dispersed
soon after our interviews,
but the expectation is that this kind
of morbidity continued for years to come.
But in addition to the direct effects
of being exposed to bombs and bullets
are the indirect effects.
The indirect effects come not because
they were maimed, or injured, or killed
by exploding ordnance or by bullets.
It's because they have been affected
by the destruction of
the essentials of life,
what happened to food supplies,
what happened to shelter, what
happened to water supplies
in the face of conflict,
and displacement becomes dramatic
in these kinds of scenarios.
Most displaced people
in war, children in war,
are what we call IDPs,
internally displaced persons.
They're not refugees.
They do not cross borders.
They are someplace else
in their home country,
but seeking shelter someplace else.
The displacement coming
out of the Middle East,
Central Africa, Myanmar,
now Latin America,
can be dramatic.
There's also destruction of
healthcare infrastructure,
and these are photographs taken
of direct hits, targeted hits
against health infrastructure
in different areas of the world.
Here, in the Middle East, this is an MSF,
Doctors Without Borders, facility
that was hit by Syrian bombs
several times in Syria.
This is very recent.
This is just a few weeks ago.
This is in North Kivu.
This is one of the
Ebola treatment centers,
because we have an outbreak
of Ebola in a war zone,
in North Kivu in the
Democratic Republic of Congo,
but because of the complexity
of the political situation,
the changing nature
of militias aligning with the government,
with the UN peacekeepers,
or with other militias,
unknown assailants came in and burned down
the MSF Ebola facility in
North Kivu just recently.
MSF had to shut down its
Ebola activities in the area
despite the fact that the Ebola
epidemic continues to grow.
Also, the social fabric of
community life evaporates,
and that social fabric is critical
to the protection of children.
One manifestation, a deeply
tragic manifestation, is rape.
More and more information is coming out
that victims of sexual
assault in these situations,
the assailants are not
only roving militias
or armies that are coming through,
but in fact, the assailants are people
that the victims know, that the breakdown
of community relations,
community protections
when people are displaced, when they begin
to flee violent assault, those protections
of community life begin to break down,
and the prohibitions to things like rape
by people who victims
know begin to evaporate,
and you get situations like we've had
in the Kivus for the last 20 years.
When I was in North
Kivu, I saw this poster,
and found it particularly compelling
in recognizing, by local people,
what the challenge of sexual assault
in the area continues to be.
If you look at the statistics,
and this is from some
tabulations that we did,
of looking at direct, bombs
and bullet, mortality,
and mortality from the indirect effects,
the destruction of the essentials of life
in different conflicts,
we began to compare,
and what you can see is that,
in most of these major conflicts,
indirect effects are much
larger than the direct effects,
that the longterm implications,
particularly for children,
of destroying the essentials
of life becomes more dramatic
than the direct effects.
Now, what does that look like?
Well, this is a study that was done
in Darfur in Western Sudan.
At the height of the fighting,
they looked at mortality, and there was,
of course, excess mortality,
but the vast majority
of that excess mortality was not due
to violence, directly speaking.
It was the indirect effect
that was most dramatic.
It was the indirect effects
that were predominant.
Same thing in the Eastern Congo,
and this is for little
kids, less than five.
You could see what the causal epidemiology
of young child mortality was.
Now, the mortality was elevated,
but for people who do global child health,
you'll recognize, this is
exactly the same distribution
of causes as you get in global
settings all over the world.
It's just that the absolute
rates were elevated,
that the indirect effects take on the form
that always are threatening
kids in these situations.
This is what it looks like.
This is an indirect effect.
This is malnutrition.
This is malaria.
This is starvation.
This is cholera.
The thing to remember
about all of these causes
of death is that 75% of all of
these deaths are preventable
with interventions that we have right now.
We don't need to come up, UCSF, Stanford,
doesn't need to come up
with any brilliant new interventions.
With interventions we have now,
we could prevent 75% of the
indirect deaths associated
with conflict around the world.
If you look at something
like neonatal mortality,
and you just list the country
with the highest neonatal
mortality in the world,
and then you just keep going down,
the top 20, they're all
countries in conflict.
It's important to recognize
that global child health
is increasingly becoming
global child health in conflict
because so much of the
residual child mortality
is now occurring in places at war.
I'm going to describe one case
that we've been examining in detail
over the last several months,
and that is the cholera epidemic in Yemen.
This cholera epidemic
is the largest epidemic
of cholera in recorded history.
Yemen remains the worst
humanitarian catastrophe
on the planet today.
This is what cholera and
malnutrition look like.
This is what the indirect effects
of war look like.
Part of our team was looking
at the cholera
preparedness, the treatment,
the epidemiology, but our
job at Stanford was to look
at what Saudi airstrikes and the blockade
by Saudi and US forces have been doing
to the humanitarian situation,
particularly the cholera, in Yemen.
What we found was things
that look like this.
This is a desalination plant
on the west coast of Yemen,
and there's heavy reliance on desalination
because of where they're located.
This is after a double
tap Saudi airstrike.
Double tap is, they hit it,
they assess what damage they've done,
and then come back the
next day to finish it off.
This was not inadvertent
collateral damage,
that the Saudi airstrikes were attempting
to destroy water infrastructure
to put pressure on the civilian population
that was considered to be supportive
to the Houthi rebels backed by Iran.
This is the destroyed
Coca Cola bottling plant
that also bottled water in Yemen
after a double tag strike.
We found evidence for 74 or so airstrikes
on water infrastructure,
civilian water infrastructure
in Yemen that we feel contributing
to the cholera outbreak.
People with disabilities
are at enhanced risk
in these situations,
particularly the direct effects,
but even moreso, the
longer-term indirect effects.
The literature on what happens
to kids with disabilities,
particularly developmental disabilities,
is relatively nonexistent, but we know
that there are 93 million kids
in the world with disabilities.
We also know that they tend
to have at least double
the mortality rates
from direct effects
because of the difficulties
in fleeing and seeking shelter
in conflict situations.
They're also more likely to
be abandoned or separated,
which also holds important implications
for indirect effects.
They lose meds, assisted devices,
and we know that they
are at increased risk,
particularly if they're
girls, of sexual assault.
Again, these are in the curricula,
but the data that we have
just speak to enhanced vulnerabilities,
and as a pediatrician working in areas
with complex political
environments and violence,
this is a special concern for us,
particularly in areas
affected by indirect effects.
There are vulnerabilities,
there are structural challenges
because of their exclusion
from the main mechanisms
of protection, of escape, and provision
that exist in these very
complicated places to be.
Also that their strengths
are rarely taken advantage of
in preparedness, in
addressing the challenges
that confront these communities
when they are under stress.
One thing that does come through
in many of the experiences,
in the journals,
and even in some of the analytic pieces
is how children with disabilities,
developmental disabilities,
rally to provide leadership,
to provide guidance for
the communities in need.
It's something that remains an advantage,
but that is rarely
exploited in the real world.
To finish, I'm going to discuss children
in a complex political
environment driven by violence,
and that is kids in detention
on our southern border.
I've had the privilege of
visiting separated detained kids
in detention centers on the US border
over the last six months.
In two weeks, I'll be going
to the detention center in Homestead.
A more detailed discussion
of immigrant kids,
the trauma, the implications, longterm,
Fernando will be talking
about in a few minutes.
I'm going to focus on the
political dynamics here.
These are the places that kids are held
in the first week or
so of their detention.
They come through a system that was built
for young adult males because
it was primarily Mexican,
young adult males that were caught up
in US border detention
facilities for decades,
but now, 65% of the
people who are detained
on our US southern
border are families, 65%,
and this has changed primarily
since the separation policy was instituted
by the Trump administration.
I know it sounds paradoxical.
I didn't make a mistake,
but the big increase
in kids coming across
the border has occurred
since the institution of
the separation policy.
Why?
It's a complicated set of reasons
that we can get into in the Q&A,
but the reality is that the border patrol,
the US government, is unprepared
to handle all these
families with children.
They are no longer routinely
separating young kids
from parent on the border.
I said routinely.
There are still separations taking place,
but this is the tent city that was set up,
Tornillo, Texas, outside of El Paso,
to hold kids who were either unaccompanied
when they came across or were separated
from their families as soon
as they came into detention.
This is the Casa Padre facility,
you can see it's an old
Walmart, in Brownsville, Texas,
that holds about 1,500 kids.
I was there in late spring,
early summer, about three weeks
after the separation
policy had been rescinded,
but there were thousands
of separated kids,
some as small as six months of age,
that were in detention or had been placed
in foster care in cities
across the country,
Chicago, Minneapolis, New York City.
One child that I
interviewed in Brownsville,
David, and they were
virtually all Guatemalan,
they're all Central Americans,
but this one little kid, David,
just full disclosure, I've been working
in Highland Guatemala for 48 years now,
since college, freshman year of college,
and David was 10 years of age,
had been separated from his mom,
had been in detention
for about seven weeks,
had no clue what was
happening with his case.
I was there with lawyers,
'cause they're allowed to go in
because of court order.
I went with them, and the lawyer
who was speaking to David first has to go
through a script, a humane script
that says, if you're not comfortable
answering these questions, don't answer.
If you want us to stop, just say so,
obviously, in Spanish.
The lawyer spoke very good Spanish,
going through the script,
more legal, legal, legal, legal, legal,
kind, but pretty much legalese.
Then she stopped, and turned to David,
and said, "How are you doing?"
David thought for a second and said,
"I miss my mommy."
These are little kids caught up
in a system built for adult males.
We don't know how many kids
were actually separated,
but we do know that there
have been two deaths
of young children in US
detention facilities,
two little Guatemalan kids,
same kids that we had been caring for
in their home villages in the Highlands,
indigenous Highlands of Guatemala.
Now, the specifics of what happened
in these deaths, I can't speak to
because I don't know all the details,
but my strong view in
knowing what I do know
is that this was a failure
that was systematic,
that 200 people are apprehended
by one border patrol agent on a border
in a remote location,
taken to a holding facility
about an hour away, the holding
facility is basically cells
to process people, then taken
to a second processing center
another few hours away,
and they may be held
in those facilities for days,
up to a week, sometimes, even longer
before the kids, and now, with the parent,
will be taken to either a
holding facility for families,
the vast majority are
released with a court date
to present for asylum-seeking.
These kids died during that first week,
during the first few days
in that detention process.
That the system makes
it extremely dangerous
for children in these settings,
particularly if you get sick.
These were kids who were previously well
who died in detention, in custody
because of acute illness.
Now, many people I've
spoken to around the country
about these issues will
have strong opinions.
I'll talk to strong Trump-backers,
anti-immigrant, hardcore.
Virtually all will say
that the separation policy was a mistake,
that even the hardcore
anti-immigrant group
will say, look, this was a mistake,
it should never have happened,
but what you also hear all the time is
that it's the parents' fault
because they are irresponsible
to put these kids
into these risky situations,
with the risk of death,
but also, look, you put the
kid in this risky position,
getting separated, it's
irresponsible parenting
that puts the kid at
risk, not our policies.
There are irresponsible parents
that try to game the system
who do put kids at risk.
However, I want to show you this slide.
Now, you're not gonna be able
to necessarily read all of this,
but this is violent death rates
by country for the most
violent places on earth.
Syria is the most violent place on earth,
the highest death rates,
but look what's number two.
Salvador.
Number three, Venezuela,
Honduras, neck and neck.
Then you get Afghanistan.
Go down the list, then you get Somalia,
then you get Yemen, and the
area that I work in most,
Guatemala, is up there on this list.
In other words, the places
with the greatest risk
of violent death other than Syria
are exactly where these
people are leaving,
that it would be irresponsible not to flee
with your child if you are living
in parts of these countries afflicted
by primarily criminal violence
that is at an epidemic proportion.
These are dangerous places
to live and to work,
so when people suggest
that placing a child
in this situation is irresponsible,
remember that slide, and remember
what the implications for
your child's wellbeing
as they grow up into being
adolescents and young adults,
what their prospects are,
what their promise would be
in settings like Venezuela,
settings like Salvador,
Guatemala, Honduras,
precisely where all these
families are coming from.
A recent report by the
inspector general basically said
that we have no clue how many kids
we separated from their
parents on the border,
and as most of you will remember,
they even lost track of which
kid belonged to which parent
because they entered into two systems,
and headquarters basically
told the people responsible
on the front line, do this now.
People, in some ways, tried their best
to have data systems that
kept the connection together,
but they were told, separate.
They lost track of which kid
belonged to which parent.
Parents were deported,
the kids were in New York, six months old,
and they had no clue which kid was which,
and what parent they belonged to.
Now, I told you I was gonna talk
about the worst and the best in the world.
I mostly talked to you about the worst.
That's my job, particularly
for an audience like this,
of professionals and strong
public advocates for children,
but there is also best.
The resilience of these kids
and their families is overwhelming.
People ask, is this
extremely depressing work,
to be working in war zones
and areas of violence, and the answer,
of course, it's deeply
troubling and distressing,
sometimes, terribly depressing,
but it's also remarkably
rewarding and invigorating.
I often say when I come back
from my time in Guatemala,
I'm there every couple of months,
I come back exhausted and
energized at the same time.
It's experiences like this,
a child in Iraq who I met,
that make it rewarding, invigorating,
energizing, and then you meet people
like Sister Norma in McAllen, Texas,
who runs a Catholic
charity's respite center.
Basically, families are in lock up.
They get released en masse.
They walk two blocks, like a caravan,
down the street with
their little belongings
to Sister Norma, and Sister Norma
and the respite center will provide them
with hot meals, guidance,
because they all have bus tickets,
'cause they're given bus tickets to go
to wherever they're gonna go,
and the bus station is nearby,
but before they do, they're given showers,
food, clothing, and,
at times, medical care,
medical care provided by volunteers
from around the country that come in
for a week at a time and
see a bunch of patients,
but it may be an adult
neurologist seeing six-year-olds
who just came through, could
be a month, in detention,
months coming up from Central America.
This is what global
health used to look like
20 or 30 years ago.
One of our efforts with
colleagues at UCSF,
and Baylor, and groups in New York is
to elevate the needs of
these facilities caring
for families leaving detention
before they disperse around the country,
and particularly once they get
to wherever they're gonna go
to have exquisitely high
quality pediatric followup.
That this should not only rely
on Sister Norma and Catholic charities.
We need to strengthen in places,
build an infrastructure
of pediatric social work,
nursing, care that is responsive
to the needs, responsive to
the demands of these families.
In closing, my suggestion
is that your expertise,
the importance of what's
gonna be discussed
in this conference is directly relevant
to the future of kids in war,
both in public advocacy, but also because
of your technical expertise
and longstanding
commitment to the wellbeing
of children in complex
social environments.
My bottom line is that, while I've talked
about the worst in the world,
child death, disabling conditions,
morbidity, emotional trauma,
that's really very hard
for all of us to fathom.
It is also the domain
of compassionate care,
of a basic humanity in the face
of traumatic horrors of war.
Thank you.
(audience claps)